dark blazer white shirt red or blue
pattern tie this is the unchanging
uniform of one Washington's most
respected insiders and the Justice
Department's pick to lead the
investigation into Russia's interference
in the 2016 election the choice of
robert mueller for special counsel has
been met with unusual universal praise
from both sides of the aisle I think
he's a person of great integrity he'll
be above politics
you will not push them around completely
unimpeachable in all respects he will
investigate the matter and follow the
facts wherever they may lead from
decorated war hero to crusading
prosecutor to unyielding FBI director
this is how robert mueller came to be
considered the least biased man in
America Robert Swan Mueller the third
grew up in Philadelphia and attended
high school at the prestigious st.
Paul's School there he captained the La
Crosse soccer and hockey teams Muller
attended Princeton where he majored in
politics before receiving a masters from
NYU the death of a former Princeton
lacrosse teammate in Vietnam drove
Muller to join the Marine Corps in
Vietnam he commanded a rifle platoon
receiving a number of decorations
including the Purple Heart it wasn't the
army for the Navy he was a Marine he had
the toughest most hardcore of the Armed
Forces that's Greg Ferrell a reporter
legal affairs and regulatory issues at
blue Berg after getting his law degree
from the University of Virginia Mueller
rose quickly through the ranks as a
federal prosecutor as chief of the
Justice Department's Criminal Division
Muller oversaw several high-profile
cases including Panama dictator Manuel
Noriega mafia boss John Gotti and the
Lockerbie bombing Moeller had a quick
stint in private practice but it wasn't
for him he quit his job as a very highly
paid white-shoe law firm partner to
prosecute homicide cases in the nation's
capital that's the dedication that you
see there in 2001 President Bush
appointed Mueller to FBI director he is a
bit of a taskmaster he wanted to upgrade
the quality of the office was good it
wasn't Pleasant for everyone who was
there but it was something that needed
to be done
the FBI changed markedly under his
leadership exactly one week after
starting in 2001 the September 11th
attacks happened a lot of people you
came as being a very steady hand after
than unless attacks that's Chris Sturm
Bloomberg national security reporter
reshaping the FBI to become a
counterterrorism agency and also
building up the cyber security and at
the end of Mueller's 10-year tenure
President Obama moved for a special
two-year extension both times mower was
nominated to run the FBI he was
unanimously approved by Congress it was
not all smooth sailing though mowers
principals were put to a significant
test in 2004 over president bush's
warrantless surveillance programs
secretly launched after September 11th
the secret surveillance program needed
to be reauthorized by this very general
who at that time was John Ashcroft and
Ashcroft would sit in the hospital
on the night of March 10th 2004 several
high-profile White House officials were
on their way to pressure Ashcroft to
sign papers extending the program when
ash grass wife interviewed she reached
at the Deputy Attorney General's James
coming hung up called director Muller
and told him what was happening he said
I'll meet you at the hospital right now
in a showdown at George Washington
Hospital baller and closes - its side by
side to prevent officials from the Bush
administration from trying to force
astronauts to reauthorize the program
while laying in his hospital bed
threatening to resign molar and Comey
were able to get the program altered the
secret program looks likely wouldn't
have come out shadows if Mullen totally
did not take a stand against it mowers
long-standing relationship with Comey
has led to questions about whether he
can remain impartial in his current
investigation it's clear from his almost
forty years of public service that
Mueller is dedicated to the job it'd have
to be pretty much a dead end er to not
believe Bob Mueller while investigating allegations of
collusion between Trump and Russia may
be his toughest case yet can't think of
anybody who will be better than Mahler
due to the investigation he's had a
history of standing up to power he said
he's had
basing our president it's one of the
most important jobs of his life once
again he's answering a call to duty
[Music]